how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about Marvel and of
course all things relating to the MCU
and today we have some very exciting
news about the setup of a Namor coming
to the MCU and the possible sinking of
Atlantis which of course is where Namor
is from in the Eternals now phase four
is going to set up a lot of new
characters or at least set them up to
appear in phase five and we've actually
already received a couple of Easter eggs
for Namor in the MCU setting him up
which of course I'll talk about in this
video and Namor is an x-men so of course
this is setting up the x-men to come to
the MCU as well and speaking of the
x-men I'll be teaming up with the real
rejects Greg and John super awesome guys
for a video tomorrow but we need your
help we want to know who you think would
play the best new Wolverine so not Hugh
Jackman in the MCU you can check out my
latest community post in the community
tab and you can vote on your answer
there and be sure to subscribe and hit
that notification bell so you can see
the video when it comes out tomorrow so
this report comes from the website MCU
cosmic and Daniel RPK now many of us
thought that they may introduce Namor in
Black Panther 2 because of the rivalry
between Atlantis and Wakanda in the
comics but as this report notes Marvel
does like to set things up way in
advance so Black Panther 2 could very
well be named wars full introduction to
the MCU however they are going to set
him up to appear in the MCU beforehand
and if you think about it that's exactly
what Marvel does the Super Soldier Serum
was introduced in the Incredible Hulk
before we saw it in Captain America
Captain America then introduced
vibranium before Wakanda was named in
Avengers age of Ultron which eventually
led to the introduction of black panther
in Captain America Civil War so this is
what Marvel has been known to do setting
things up way in advance and according
to this report and MCU cosmic much like
these early references to Black Panther
and his set up in the MCU before the
actual movie MCU cosmic has heard rumors
that this could be happening for name
wear as well introducing Atlantis in the
Eternals specifically the sinking of
Atlantis on screen now it seems very
clear that Namor is headed to the MCU
because this will not be the first
reference to Namor that we've got in the
MCU the first one comes from
all the way back in iron man to shield
has a map pulled up and in the map we
can see several locations one of which
is Wakanda and this took place eight
years before black panther came out so
Marvel Studios knew eight years in
advance that they were going to
introduce black panther eventually
because that's what Marvel does they're
awesome and they planned that far in
advance however there is another
location mark on that same map right
over the middle of the Atlantic Ocean
which is Atlantis so perhaps Marvel has
known for an extremely long time that
they are going to eventually introduce
Namor as well and then of course we have
the Easter egg in Avengers end game
where a [ __ ] talks about an earthquake
in the middle of the Atlantic Ocean she
then says it's an earthquake in the
Atlantic Ocean the way we deal with it
is to not deal with it and it's widely
believed that she says this because she
knows that it's actually the Atlanteans
again the Atlanteans and the wakandans
have a long history together in the
comics so they definitely know about
each other and they're not exactly
friends which is probably why she said
we're not going to deal with it so we've
had a few setups for Namor before but
now it seems like we're going to get one
more before his official introduction
the Eternals is going to take place over
35,000 years of the MCU and we know that
the film is going to explore ancient
Babylon during this time or some other
time in the ancient past the support
says that since they're going that far
back in time and that they've heard
rumors of Atlantis being in the Eternals
it's the perfect opportunity to show
Atlantis sinking because if you're not
familiar with Atlantis lore it was above
water until it eventually sunk
namor the sub-mariner made his debut
with Marvel Comics in 1939 and it was
one of the first Marvel characters
introduced he's also considered as the
first mutant in the Marvel Universe as
well and for those of you who aren't
aware Namor possesses the super-strength
and aquatic abilities of the homo Merman
s race as well as the mutant ability to
fly along with many other superhuman
abilities he has been a member of the
x-men
The Avengers the defenders and the
Illuminati he also played a major role
in the Avengers of vs the x-men and led
the
back on Wakanda with the Phoenix force
so as you can see the introduction of
name war to the MCU could lead to many
other introductions of really awesome
storylines to the MCU as well so what do
you think about name war possibly being
set up in the Eternals let me know your
thoughts in the comments down below
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe when notifications turned on
to stay up to date on everything
relating to the MCU and so you can enter
my giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
one or ps4 I'm picking a winner at five
hundred and fifty thousand subscribers
as always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof